oh I'm playing Christopher you a very
strong player okay not too much time to
interact with the chat things chat for
still sticking around I actually don't
know Chris's repertory I know it was
sort of his black repertory and thanks
for the bits joking I played Chris once
and uh the pro the pro Shasta actually
their very first season of the protest
see the first game notice welcome back
is he gonna play - yeah Queen f3 this is
what all the all the kids are playing
these days kids and adults so might have
six I think I looked at this in
preparation for my OB memetchi I vaguely
remember Chris having a game in this
lion oh man so this is gonna take was it
Chris I was studying like the most
trendy theory there is a card yakking
game and I think there's a Christopher
you game so b5 and there's some weird
line like a three here and then takes
and then Bishop rook c8 that's a line
where no moves makes sense but you have
to know all the theory mean mystery
chess remain welcome back
hopefully is good and mean it's still a
state I've I've never been to it's nice
to see him thinking here I think there's
two main movie series i for yeah for as
a move so my chief like g4 right 94
there's a line a five takes takes and
then B for which I actually had recently
in a title Tuesday
there's also Bishop here
that's another yeah theist so many
branches to this line
trying to remember Bishop g1 Bishop e7
oh so he takes okay so at least I'm
somewhat knowledgeable here there's
another line takes takes takes and then
rook c8 takes takes and then I think
blacks winning but yeah the whole the
whole reason why this is playable for
black is before after Queen zigs III if
I didn't have before and then it
probably was just really bad that's nice
these lines are still a little bit fresh
I looked at this probably a week and a
half ago it's it's funny cuz I prepared
this for a Lina and not only did she not
go into this but she didn't play e4 in a
single game that's one thing like when
you prepare for specific opponents
you'll be really motivated to like learn
learn these lines deeply and then even
if they don't happen against the
specific opponents they'll happen
eventually so Chris is taking his time
he's probably calculating this yeah my
most recent know it was title Tuesday
from maybe a couple weeks ago I'd kind
of forgot what to do after this and I I
checked afterwards with engine so the
engine was giving yeah takes takes takes
rough GI takes takes and then the
Queen's hits and the knight the Knights
not trapped on you on because I can
trade off it should just be a good
position
again with this click click yeah so
Chris taking this time Chris is like
very strong tactically so yeah it's
gonna be a tactical position to
regardless of what happens I think this
is a one area that maybe I'm I have some
chance at least in the opening I get
some really momentum all right we got
Eric Rosen black against Christopher you
very theoretical Sicilian Eric Rosa gets
black every game the truth hurts still
theory pretty sure actually he played
the this puzzle rush he qualified for
this puzzle rush world championship or
puzzle battle he was right below the the
tier of of Ray Robson and Hans Neiman so
actually I have a friend who's also a
streamer Grandmaster Kevin Kevin Ming
from Singapore and Kevin actually had a
game in this line Kevin was white I
believe and he just got crushed it went
exactly like this I explained I
explained earlier why I'm playing this
thanks for subbing I guess ok I think
yeah I don't remember the Kevin game
exactly but I'm pretty sure this was
played and then King b1 in Bishop digs
you sat on i-25 I think just bishop f8
always play King b1 go Christopher you
yeah Bishop f8 saw me move after 905 but
it should still be good for black number
black one like really quickly that game
by forgets I'm forgetting like what the
the main idea was was something on the
Queen side
an extra pond rose in three minutes on
the clock
but Christopher use a lot younger than
him no actually I did review that game
um in my prep for Alina but I only
review that very briefly because it's
one of those lines like if you get your
you're happy with and you should focus
your energy on more critical lines am I
remembering I guess I guess of Queen g4
then rook g8 I have to stop 96 I mean on
the surface it looks really shaky for
black because the King's in the center
the light looks like a knife and what
keeps initiative but then this because
there's 96 there it's a point count I'm
technically up upon not sure how much
this pawn matters I think in the in the
Kevin game the pawn actually just
survived until da right if we use
fighting back
he's like knife f5 he's like my protege
King b19 a f5 and he's as a bad position
that's like me I was briefly looking at
Queen here rook here night here we trade
everything and then something mm
something like Keaney Savin rook rook
beatings so bitter be to make some sense
yeah now now I'm just on my own don't
remember anything so clear to provide
much benefit but okay Bishop e7 mr.
Bathory rook see it comes to mind also
the queen is kind of tied down to
pinning the pawn which it's kind of nice
there's some Bishop each five idea I
don't think I'm too concerned maybe more
realistic as like rook t2 and then
doubling up for whites and yeah Bishop
g5 not quite possible and Bishop c5 is a
move
there should be seven well your get
there should be seven has a threaded
Bishop c5 Knight g7 King f8 I'll play
Bishop e7 one of these moves that might
make him start thinking your time is
very much in my favor but again don't
want to get too relaxed Brooke d4 okay
so Bishop c5 looks looks like the
obvious choice I guess he wants to play
rook c4 it gets weird there G choose
hanging but that's probably not so
relevant okay that wrote d4 interesting
idea wondering if I can just play rook
c8 rook c4 and Queen a5
and we trade light would be attacked
light moves I move the bishop back then
there's Bishop t5 ideas might be the way
to go
if white doesn't go for that I mean see
choose attack so I probably has to go
for that I always have to be careful of
queenie 525 is never real concern let's
try this lady queen d4 in 24 should be a
concern well gee - okay so the line I'm
looking at is rook see for Queen 85
takes takes Queen d4 and then rook g8 96
we trade but then I went g2 in that and
it's still a mess
I should really keep calculating so
takes takes Queen D 1496 there's some
king da but okay let's say takes takes
and then takes i'm sure the king is
quite safe there and the bishops hit c2
is a target like there's no Rick T 1
because a bishop defends g7 and it's
official about 3 there's about 3 oh then
maybe there's this rook D to move
because the Queen defends and it's it's
the Queen on d6 its Queen p8 their queen
be a queen C 3 nice move at acting the
bishop and defending my bishop and
hitting c2 I was just meeting unless
Bishop e4 should be fourth line keeps
going
d5 Bishop d3 plays Queen g4 right away
this could just transpose the Knights
hanging but I can't take it just yet
it's probably transposing oh he wants to
know he wants to check me for the
rookie's under attack
it's the most complicated game of all
time but to be sharp at Taos huh
um so I could consider taking
hmm forget all about that move and
there's a lot too many options here rook
takes e4 basically forces Bishop takes
e4 and then Brooke g8 rook t1 yeah
that's probably a better version for
whites
there's d5 though in that line so the
ideas takes takes rook g8 rook to e1 and
then d5 and the Knights hit and this is
hit but the bishops not actually hit cuz
pawns pinned but okay let's let's go
ahead and take there's Queen takes here
- Wow just failed to consider that as a
dangerous option yeah it's actually
quite dangerous
yeah because ninety six is a threat my
rooks hanging
I have to go crazy here I was a really
good move takes takes I mean I could I
could play the position down the
exchange like takes takes takes the
problem is ninety six is a threat so
there is rook c6 here which looks very
grotesque but it might be the way to go
covering covering ninety six and lights
attacks like g7 Qing Yi sudden there's
no not h5 yeah it's probably the way to
go and just holds things together it's
gonna come down to time probably 94 is a
move 94 idea for maybe rook t6 my funny
square but actually makes sense like
this Bishop is just chillin Bishop keeps
the King safe this Bishop is about to
chill even even more on d5 be a great
square for the bishop
Brooksie sex I think was nice nice move
just to stay composed now 56
I guess might be three expected this
very weird configuration
we're both lacking some harmony might be
three may be queen of five might be
three queen of five there's a d3 I
probably just sack or maybe just take on
that for mmm he wants to make things
tactical I wonder a Bishop d5 here it
should be fine it might be three
actually that just looks very close to
winning the c4 doesn't work
so lady is after this all the Queen can
come back and win b2 but okay night b3 I
take the e pawn can't take his mates so
C pawn has to take I was thinking takes
oh yeah that doesn't win takes takes
Queen here Queen B - I win the bishop
I thought c4 didn't work but maybe it
that's a try Bishop here okay this looks
very close to meeting but where's the
meet
there could be six Bishop still pinned
before okay let's start with rook b6
what those was calculate Murphy six
theirs might be three point eight three
King King a one-room takes b6 who's
winning
rook b6 there's King c1 but then queen
c3 is winning yeah the bishop is
actually useful in supporting the Queen
even though it's pinned it still defends
the a3 square actually even more
beautiful okay I mean the triple check
this but rook takes b3 I think is just
um Oh work takes b3 plunge xb3 and line
keeps going Queen a3
oh there's King c3 - hmm okay it should
still be winning its play Queen c3 a
king c3 or Queen a three-team C 3 and
I'll take on e2 I could repeat once I'll
take on any two first even bigger than
when Rosen beat Magnus Carlsen last year
even bigger go Rosen what you thought
Rosen beat me but didn't be Carlsen
come on ridiculous okay here I just want
to calculate the mates
[Music]
okay just vertex b3 nothing to think
about
and then Queen B - keeping initiative
and then King Daisy for clean easy - and
then I win the rook okay that was a nice
game it was very nice
I think the the opening preparation I
mean really really helped I I'll have to
check I probably won't have time to
check now but I'll check after the the
tournaments if I was remembering
correctly with us with his game in the
database
yeah that was probably my my proudest
game cuz Christmas Christopher's what
he's like half my age but he's he was a
clear favorite he's he's on the verge of
becoming a GM probably one of the
strongest ions in the world yeah so okay
I can actually go to the geo scene yeah
so this was my prep for Lina and just to
show I did so much crap from from the
back side against Queen f3 time on of
and it's like it's so nice I guess it
wasn't nice that it wasn't useful
against aleena but it's nice to
eventually be able to to use some prep
so actually so if I go back so just to
show what happened in the the
Christopher game I'll show how it
compares to the prep so it was very
theoretical mine where we basically got
this position I defied Bishop Fe I think
this is all Pratt so to show this file
maybe I'll move myself if I ever played
gari I played gari when I was like ten
years old I still remember how I lost to
him I think he was 1800 at the time I
thought he was a god because he had a
Wikipedia page and he yeah he he had
some knight takes each six tactic we
both remember it I played gari a bunch
of times over the years actually played
him I played them last year almost
exactly a year ago we drew in seven
moves I made the whole YouTube video
about it I also got some hate mail
people so upset that I I could draw a
game as white and 7 News
well that was after we had both played
like for our games or two games in one
day anyway so maybe for the people who
are not so familiar with how the opening
rapper towards work at a high level this
is this is very kind of what you have to
do to learn openings and to save save
your preparation is have a file I'd say
you any any master level player well
we'll use chess base to study chess and
just save their openings
maybe they these days there's all their
resources I mean of course we chess but
the software has been around for for
well over a decade probably two decades
and we played through the main line
I'd mentioned during the game oh it was
I was not I was not Kuryakin it was MVL
gotta gain here dies remembering that
Chris you had some game in this line and
then being impressed that that he was so
well prepared and like when you first
play through these this line like almost
none of the moves make sense like Bishop
takes b5 you really have to dig in
deeply to each move to understand it's
like somehow the sacrifice works with
white wins a bunch of pawns I want to go
into too many details so black just kind
of ignores it just absolutely everyone
in their entire extended family is right
now that's crazy this is what happens
it's a Saturday and it was uh it was a
been final tournament
it was the Leach has titled arena it's
like kind of late afternoon so Europeans
should still be awake also the whole
world is basically in lockdown so that
kind of contributes to two things
there's nothing else to do thanks for
solving for twenty months
Charlotte to just a blue
a long time mod and steamer yeah do I
have I don't have a just a blue command
but yeah people should subscribe to just
a blue for the for the emotes there's
there's some very relevant emotes for
today's world anyway so this is
preparation that if he went into I would
have I would have struggled remembering
these moves I would have remembered work
seeing probably would have remembered
this and what's the move t6 no Queen a5
that's so crazy
and this is very cutting edge like there
is um so maybe there was no Christopher
you game I really thought Christopher
had a game well maybe his Mishra Mishra
is another like young I think he's a
youngest I am in the u.s. yeah it was
that game Christopher you ever play this
let's go back maybe before 83 just do a
search for you now maybe he hasn't had
this position in the database okay so in
that regard I kind of I was probably
just making up a fake memory but we went
into a line which was this move order
and yeah my friends actually the first
time I ever saw this line my friend was
showing it to me Kevin who's also a
streamer and he was white he got destroy
than this and then he's I think he
started playing in this black and we
followed we followed his game I promote
this
yeah Queen Jake's III before yeah so
this is exact same position we had in
the the Christopher you game like we can
we can see Bishop FA that's it's
identical and then then I just kind of
forgot what to do I think I guess
Christopher deviated he played he didn't
play Queen g3 he played Brooke well do
you play here he played Bishop e2
but I think already like this is
supposed to be good for black allowing
this I think the mistake was actually
allowing night takes III like we can we
can ask sock fish stock fish usually
understands these positions but better
but yeah it's already favoring black
after before so like this was a really
nice kind of model game because black oh
Kim D I don't don't remember King D it's
the lack essentially got the King safe
and then exploited whites Queen side a
bit of d5 was - and then the a bishop
takes a - really nice finish rook c5 and
then it was some ending and game but box
still is like having mating ideas that
was just over so yeah it's very nice to
kind of play the opening quickly and
then get get this position where yeah I
basically knew that blocks better so
oops what did I just do going back to
the chest calm scene I do have Liva I
don't think I don't think the hardware
is like so great with Lila by I do have
Lila so when I study openings these days
at least in chess Vedas all have Mila
and stockfish providing some opinions